I don't know if I want kids it's really
unfair that if you miss your period your
only two options are murder or putting a
human being through college why do you
have to be a mom to stay at home be like
a stay at home person or something like
that that's not an option how am I gonna
deal with postpartum depression when I
can't even deal with prepartum
depression messed up my life married a
man I think all women are lesbians right
is that even a real thing I feel like a
lot of lesbians are just female
roommates that turn 30 let's be honest I
[Applause]
never realized like all this equal
rights equal pay legislation would pass
I never thought any woman would ever be
able to make enough money for me to live
off of
stuck with this dude now anyone out
anyone married for thrilled people you
guys never get to that point sometimes I
look at my husband
and then I look out the window and I
just feel like every person walking down
the street is the one that got away
[Applause]
you got to do it right I mean you gotta
do something life is long I tried to get
into a nightclub recently and I got to
the door and the bouncer was like now we
good and that's when I realized like
that's why people settle down and have
families because eventually you're just
too ugly to have fun anymore I mean once
you can't get into nightclubs you might
as well just create someone else that
can there's nothing else to do not white
I don't have any hobbies
I know to yoga I'm Indian we just owned
the rights to it I walked into a yoga
class once in my life and everyone was
like are you our guru the instructor has
always liked some white chick named
Shiva I went to India to find herself
whatever that means what does that even
mean and like why do you have to go all
the way to India to do it why would we
be hiding white people's souls in our
country that's what I love about white
people though why people are subscribers
you know just get into [ __ ] I'll go to
Peace Corps dance at your Indian wedding
learn Spanish I mean white people are so
giving that they believe Deepak Chopra
[Applause]
thank you I get it you know you get into
things veganism that's another thing now
I can't I can't eat cheese I'm sorry I'm
a I'm a vegan we have a term for that in
the third world
it's called poverty I think we should
just take all of the vegans and just
throw them out into the wild so they can
get eaten by the animals they spent
their lives trying to say I'm having a
girl thank you I think it's a good time
for women right now though you know
we're all coming together sharing our
stories our voices are finally being
heard not all women though you know some
of us haven't had the privilege of being
sexually harassed
[Applause]
more it's been going on like I'm just
starting to feel left out
it's trying to get insulting like every
woman has been harassed really every
single woman has been harassed the hell
is wrong with me I told my boss that I
would do anything for a promotion and he
goes that's all right
hashtag not me
[Applause]
you